the best kind of love story is a
self-love story you can take this from
me i've learned this through many hard
lessons
that it's not about finding true love
it's not about finding your soulmate
it's not about you
it's about me
hello i'm back with cooking simulator
i said that i wasn't gonna or i said
that i might or i said that if there was
enough demand i would i don't remember
which one of those scenarios was the
case
but largely independently from that i
decided to play it again myself
modern is what i was gonna do no
tutorial needed here
so i'm not cooking in the 1950s like
some
old guy i'm cooking in 2021
like me and i'm gonna keep calm and cook
on
so i'm going into this with the
knowledge that i kept from the last time
and i'm going to make
modern dishes in a modern kitchen and
i'm going to start
right from the get-go when there's
actual customers on the line
oh god here we go within an hour we'll
be open for business use that time to
get ready for it
yeah i know shut up go away oh wow
i'm going to be using that a lot where's
my up oven and
oh it's side oven interesting
right do i still have my talent i
probably don't uh
prep phase well i don't really know
what i'm doing
recipes right recipes i know those
okay not owned let's
make grilled t-bone steak and
baked red potatoes that's uh i have no
i can't own that fine no i don't have
any skills either why did i start a new
one
why didn't i just do the same one i
wanted to be in the modern and it's very
pretty this just looks like a house
kitchen this doesn't look like a
is this a restaurant why is everything
over there that's very inconvenient
modern kitchen my ass this place sucks
is this what i have oh this is a house
kitchen
this is a nice kitchen give me where's
the jank i'm
out of here this is garbage you're
garbage that is garbage
i'm going back modern is stupid i've
always said this
i want the classics i want to go back to
the time when cooking really
was about something special oh my god
terrifying hi new or new order
new what what are we going now
is it now now is happening but i i but
uh trout
okay whatever it's fine i don't remember
how to play trout
right black pep per
five five okay man i have completely
forgotten how
this goes um this kitchen's a freaking
mess
why did i come back here this clearly is
not working out for me
dill dill okay dill do i pay for like
gas and whatnot whatever i don't know
those shouldn't be here why aren't they
here they should be here why are they
there why would they be over there they
don't need to be over there let me get
my head on straight here okay put on
baking tray bake
for 90 seconds okay maybe i should get
my phone
and i should have timers so that i know
why
no oh i'm not done
wha what what what wait a minute
hang on hold up there do i need to keep
this closed or is that okay just to have
completely out in the open
don't put it on top what is wrong with
you
hang on i'll just go i'll i'll do these
both that's fine
i'll do these both right now and then i
can put them in the oven at the same
time okay so now i got both of those so
i just need the baking tray where oh
it's in here
don't you dare do anything to destroy me
one two
okay there you go i could have gotten
two baking trays i guess but it'll work
i don't have a phone i forgot about the
phone
bam go okay so when that hits 90 i know
that they're good to go
um i need to get lemons okay lemons
lamin
okay okay here we go
cut into quarters which means that i
need to
cut this way unlike what i did before
steady hands baby
oh yeah steady hands baby and then
hey yeah okay perfect we are in business
so
i'm gonna get two plates one's gonna
have four of these
do not chop the plate put that there put
that there put that there put that there
yeah uh-huh oh it's fine
it's just a floor lemon i need to season
with horseradish
and garnish with parsley so horseradish
after it's baked dried horseradish
where's that
horse right there oh
it's burning it's burning it's burning
it's hot
help hey it's fine okay pop that right
there
horseradish horseradish horseradish
the radish from horses whatever that
even means i don't really know
[Music]
bam what
what why would you accumulate them
they're two trouts it's not one tre you
better
that that is six and this is
okay whatever it's very hot okay and
then
oh my god this is the most annoying
thing
it's fine okay so now i just put one
two three okay plop that there for now
just a second one two three order up
baby
order up ding ding ding boing boing
boing donk you got a baby okay
and then yes yes yes yes perfect
this one's not gonna be as perfect
because obviously it gets complaints
none
what do you mean technique on the
parsley what's wrong with the parsley
what's wrong with the parsley what's
wrong with the part what's wrong with
parsley
what was wrong with the parsley what was
wrong with the parsley hmm
that one was perfect even though it had
a little too much horseradish apparently
but whatever
okay but i made money and made moolah
killing it
do i have a power built i bet or not if
i do i will
murder matameto soup chicken broth
which doesn't make a lot of sense do i
just
dump it throw it get out of there
that's one way to do it i guess okay is
please tell me this is like an
unlimp nope it's not um okay i should
probably like
buy oh my god shut up
wrong with you people are trying to work
here 700 milliliters
okay slow it down a bit and
[Music]
there we go nice that's pretty good okay
probably should have finished off my
other chicken broth before doing that
but i didn't so whatever
okay we need um 12 of this
and then 12 salt
oh my god cooking is like
no no intricate stop
what is wrong with you what what is
wrong with you how much is in there
wait how much is in there wait stop how
much is in there
how what how much is in there how much
did i
i think i only got five in there did i i
don't know
960 of tomato okay 960 of tomato this
looks like tomatoes
what okay
eight four
five six seven eight
okay eight of those and then one onion
what is with these people outside no
respect boil for 60 seconds you got it
plopper on there stop crank up the heat
did i need to blend that wait did i need
to blend that no boil and then blend
then sour cream how much scream i got
not enough
this is so bonkers difficult okay you
done yet
done yet you done should i have time
that i don't know
but when when is it how do i know when
it's boiling is it
boiling taste
[Music]
what do i have a spectrometer on my
tongue that's incredible that's nuts
but also how do i know when it's hot
what
it's not but what my head
my head is so in pain oh but it's
over boiling i don't know
blend it blast it turn it on
grind it
well that's done taken care of time to
put some sour cream in that bad boy 100
and uh
whatever something i don't know yeah
get in there that was 97 so i need 53
53 okay
[Music]
i got it okay cool good all right
and we're done i think bull
in a
deep plate okay can i get like a ladle
do i have a ladle can i buy a ladle how
much time i got on this enough to buy i
got i can buy a ladle
ladle ladle ladle three yeah ladle give
me a ladle
oh yeah okay ladle
did i do it i did it apparently okay
good
blasto pop her down get it off
look this soup might be just a way a bit
on the
garnish do you garnish soup nah of
course not
order up it's perfectly perfect
anyway i'm a goddamn jesus this was the
last order for today when you're done
prepare for tomorrow
how i can't be more prepared does this
keep can i put this on this pop this
away
yeah that's all i know this guy
oh my god my floor ah whatever who cares
what is a stain but another memory on
the road trip to your success
right remember that someone get that
tattooed please now
immediately don't do it actually god
please don't skip cleaning phase
why would i clean whatever
perfect day this was not very much money
it's not very much money
i killed it i get a new perk i killed it
ooh skilled yeah i'll do that i don't
need to be faster i'm going to break
everything
oh i could never break it nah i like
economy based
uh yeah sure income boost
level that up sure i think we should
expand our menu
do you simple ukrainian borsch duck
broth
roasted christmas ham how about simple
ukrainian porsche that sounds pretty
good
you're gonna need some apparently
someone said this is like uh gordon
um uh gordon ramsay i don't see the
resemblance
beetroot
carrot can now be found in the shop in
the lard of beetroot
that's not beetroot that's beetroot our
guests are more likely to order dish of
the day
don't be surprised if they choose what
do you mean dish of the day how do i
know what the dish of the day is
our main dish of the day is borsch it's
borsch
is our dish of the day i just got that
recipe
why would that be our dish of the day
who the hell made that choice
is this soup still good how's that soup
oh yeah that's some
good soup
well oh god it's actually scared me
okay trout got it close that plop around
nope
almost made it plopper on there i know
the ratios
yeah black bloom black blue black
blue i got that yeah and then five of
this i know the deal
blunt blue blue blue blue blue five of
this bad boy here
blink blink blink blink blink blank and
then
that's good there pop that on that
bake for 90. i got my timer here
oh my god i'm gonna not screw this up
boink oh okay i know that um
yeah horseradish and then uh lemon lamb
and lemon forgot the lemon lemon lemon
lemon lemon lemon lemon lemon
if i was smart yeah i guess i would be
like prepping all this stuff ahead of
the time you know like cutting a bunch
of these or
you know try to predict what i'm gonna
do that's what restaurants would do but
i also like living vicariously and
stupidly
my cutting is a little off there they're
probably gonna dock me on that one but
whatever
well i'm bored oh my god
oh my god why does it take so long okay
three
two one ding ding ding ding ding ding
got it bam put it up
i knew it was gonna happen before it
happened i knew it was gonna happen
before it happened
i'm just that smart
oh god oh my god
i will never learn my lesson okay
horseradish i need not
i forgot i need this not to be on the
lemons
is that not correct
there we go oh boy put that on there
well okay here we go and then one two
three okay there's a quality
wait where did it that's two one two
three okay do it it's falling off
that's fine order up oh what is up how
big
you got it baby i guess i'll pick this
up oh
borsch the meal of the day okay hang on
yes can wait there's gonna be more
anyway what do i
do i care okay chicken broth i don't
have enough of that
okay you're telling me that i'm not
gonna use this amazing tomato soup okay
i'm gonna use up the rest of this
well this is precarious here we go
that's fine
[Music]
okay there's 580 in there i need how
much
i don't know something a number i need a
number what's the number
hello a thousand i could have just
gotten a new bottle and that would have
been a lot easier all right
a quick math oh damn it
it's fine it'll be fine i'll take
some out and drop it
okay that's gonna taste good
okay 45.
bump oh wow that okay cool all right
uh uh uh salt pepper okay let's get the
beet root first so five beet root one
onion
one carrot okay one two three
four five one carrot yeah one carrot
one onion okay ah
[Music]
parsley root parsley
parsley
oh my god okay parsley root 80
okay put that in oh my god no
no no don't put pot on floor
stop
stop stop okay boil for 120 seconds
got it okay so i'm gonna boil it and
then add the salt and pepper while it's
boiling because
i'm efficient like that stop reset go
okay hundred and huh many seconds 120
okay
i need 20 of this okay
[Music]
okay oh well i got it on the beetroot
but i think it'll all mix anyway
um and then 20 of the pep 20 pep
[Music]
oh god oh no oh my god it's oh okay yeah
yeah
yeah okay oh my god that was a terrible
idea i'll do it anyway but that in the
future
do i blend this is this getting blasted
oh god it's not what do you do what do
you do with yourself
who even are you okay this is empty
blam this is not
empty get good
thank you okay so
[Music]
i don't know what's supposed to happen
because this
don't look like it's anything
i guess i just put the soup not any of
the other things
there's a point waste of my morse
they're wasting my borsch taste it
nice sweet sick stuff awesome epic
and yoinkus right off of there save
me money on that get me a bull
or as they call it a deep plate which is
kind of dumb but whatever
okay put two splashes of these bad boys
in there
sploosh and then a little bit of a
sploosh
pop that back up there and then uh
author up
for your porsche don't ask me what
accent that was
boom you're welcome you're like
[Music]
it's fine you know typically in life if
you
put the salt anywhere in the liquid
it'll get around i don't think
that the beet was perfectly floating
with the pile of salt on the top of it
at all times without
ever shaking any in there i don't think
that's how that went
but okay we'll go with that reality
high pork chops i'll take one
please one chop of pork
one pork of chop what salt
you got it four grams of blam blam blam
blam done pepper i bet
i'm not upset it's nice i'm not i'm not
not upset you know it's just about
learning okay sunflower oil to the right
pan sunflower oil 30 right i should have
kept what was in there before
third e2
perfect uh 90 on each side oh
god i have to flip it oh god
oh my god i forgot what if i just toss
the pan
oh god the time what if i chuck you know
oh
you know what if i what if i do that
thank god only one person comes in here
at a time
but uh i could try that i mean most good
chefs they end up doing that so
oh and potatoes
oh i forgot about the potatoes oh my god
i forgot about the potatoes oh my god
okay
okay i gotta hurry okay steady hands
activate
bam what was i supposed to cut this into
chunks
i don't exactly know what chunk mean
i'm assuming chunkus is chunkus
right okay that looks chunky uh salt
six i need more than that you
there how much time i got oh my god i'm
running out of time i gotta flip that i
gotta flip that
okay yeah okay yeah good uh
chunk chunk and then
okay flip flip time flip time put it
down put the knife down
okay flip time how do i oh i'm doing i'm
not gonna flip the air i don't have time
i'm a god okay salt six grams of salt
probably should have salted it
beforehand because apparently it doesn't
distribute
probably gonna be too much too little
salt too little too much
it's too riddling too much okay uh what
am i doing
oh god it doesn't say how long to bake
those
oh it does oh god okay it'll be done
when that's done i'll get a plate ready
for that
we'll plate it up blam easy
almost too easy you know what i'm saying
where's my knife put that back where it
needs to go i shouldn't run around with
that
and we're just
about
perfect got it okay step away
how are we doing okay not quite there
yet okay so i'm just
keep a respectable distance at all times
perfect you know you love it and i'm not
moving
that is so much potato
that is so much any garnish on this
no okay here we go god it said 300 grams
of potato
that's what it said it's not like the
picture but the picture is a lie
it's that's one potato you said 300
grams
bad cutting eat my no no
it's fine see i don't know how to rotate
them
that's the thing whatever i don't know
how that go
we expect me to know how to rotate
potatoes i can't
and refuse to salmon steak boiled
potatoes
ah okay you know what and borscht
i have borsch i got borsch okay so
that's going
i can just i'll put this in the pan
screw it
it's uh blam okay borsch
already got the borscht ready to go so
just need to
let me shake the pot a little alright
yeah we'll
get it stirred up in there okay oh
boink yeah this is good stuff yeah warm
too
hot actually uh order up
more shot the ready bub lamb get the
borscht
done out of here thank you um
what is wrong with your entire being
too cold that's correct
100 agree big agree actually
there's no keep warm setting though so
ah
excellent i will now make this warm you
will have a warm
delicious soup at the ready it's gonna
taste
earthy a little bit little earthy uh but
that's okay it's part of the experience
for the experience you know what i mean
all right this borsch is done
that salmon probably done i gotta get
holy
borsch up get it in
the better temp was better better
fame is so good strong temp is great
actually all right it's done get
shut up and go oh what
you done oh my god you are uh you uh
come with me if you want to live
what did i do okay ooh
i love it i'm so good at that i'll try
the pan technique next time or the
flippy pan technique next time
but i am goddamn good potato oh
yo water water water salt and potatoes
okay two potatoes okay two potatoes
uh potato one is i probably should have
done the same time but whatever you done
okay you're done
pretty much okay and then 20 grams of
salt
okay get the plate pop this on the plate
that's done put that right there ready
to go
um i need to salt only the water they'll
be able to tell
they know
[Music]
why is that getting on the potato i
don't want that on the
whatever i don't know god i hate
everything
i hate everything how are we doing
let me taste you delicious
good stuff good stuff i should probably
always have a pot of water boiling
and then have a pot of chicken broth
ready to go and then a frying pan with
oil
man this is just tough you know i'm
barely juggling
one at a time just trying to get by
and this son of a whoever wants to
eat it this
restaurant of mine just throws my life
for a loop
how how no
no oh that is handy that is very handy
you done yet
you done shut up you done you done edo
you done
get in here get in here all right order
uh order up order up order up bam
you're gonna love it
[Music]
uh
okay that i get you didn't want pork
chop taste in your salmon
but i say the pork adds a layer of
flavor
to it that really brings out the depth
of the fish fish and pork
if they could be lovers they would be
lovers
and in my restaurant they are lovers
and their love is made inside your mouth
you should thank me all right that
didn't go as planned but uh i
i guess this they don't like boiling
oils
i gotta make new porsche oh my god get
rid of this
yeah all right new borscht i need a
whole new leader of
god damn whatever the thing
my box broth oh i know it's a leader of
this
is it though a leader is it a leader is
it a leader
it's a leader baby okay salt and pepper
20 of each i'm doing this before any
other ingredients which is why it says
that
in the goddamn rest oh
no they're gonna know they're gonna know
they're gonna be able to tell
oh god okay beet root whatever one two
three four five one of these
never mind okay great nope
that's again not no you disappoint your
family
onion that's what i'm missing onion okay
onion onion
boink okay now we boil dwinkas well
i'll set this two minutes bam
that if once i get better at that that's
gonna be no problem at all that's gonna
be no problem
dude this is easy dude i don't even know
what i was worried about
i i was just talking a little bit ago
about how restaurants are like all hard
and difficult or whatever what does this
do i can play darts are you kidding me
yes new game where's the darts do i
gotta buy darts
buy darts hello box light beer
firecracker firecracker yes
absolutely light the fuse
all right
how do i play let me play well this is
some
i can tell you that much oh yeah i know
i know i know i i i know i know
well i didn't want that what oh what is
hat why
okay you can oh that's not how those
things
wise is on the ladle why carrot get off
of there
you're too hot shut up oh my god
you don't need it you don't need it
you're not needed
i'd all done good yes borscht
hello we've got problems everything's
wrong
what do i do with you nothing repairs
anymore
help me they're already in the kitchen
okay good we i've officially lost it
which is exactly what i was hoping to do
all right hey that's some good income
tomorrow we're getting inspected
no i i refuse i'm not gonna be a part of
that
you take your inspections and sch
so yeah that is cooking simulator more
of that that's what you wanted
apparently and
i'm glad i did that because i learned a
lot i was getting good
i was i was getting better and i can
definitely see how this could ramp up in
difficulty
uh yeah thank you shout if you want more
shout real loud
extremely loud as loud as you can open
your windows and shout
if you want more of this so thank you
and as always
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
you